[Applaus]
[Musik]
was internationale expansion angeht ist
erwin wie eines der am schnellsten
wachsenden startups der welt damit ihr
eine bessere vorstellung davon bekommt
wie irre schnell dieses firma wächst
hier ein paar eckdaten gründung in
kalifornien im februar 2008 nach nur
drei jahren machte sie bereits 75
prozent ihres geschäfts außerhalb der
usa im vergleich dazu benötigte facebook
doppelt so viel zeit um seine
internationale präsenz zu festigen und
egal von wo ihr euch dieses video gerade
an seht ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
sie irgendwann einmal erwin wie benutzt
habt
[Musik]
allein in den letzten zehn jahren
verzeichnete dienst über 400 millionen
check-ins glaubt mir wenn ich euch sage
das nicht viel unternehmen behaupten
können sie hätten eine ganze branche
derart verändert wie airbnb den
fremdenverkehr und was in unglaublich
kurzer zeit theoretisch könnte die idee
nicht brillianter seien irgendwie
ermöglicht es jedem sein haus oder seine
wohnung in ein hotel zu verwandeln und
dank dessen können viele menschen so
viel weniger geld verreisen aber nicht
nur das durch er bmw entstand eine ganz
neue generation von kleinunternehmern
heute leben weltweit tausende von
menschen von ihren erben wie einkünften
tatsächlich hat erwin die vielen studien
zufolge mehr arbeitsplätze geschaffen
als zerstört aber wartet einen moment
denn nicht alles an dieser geschichte
ist eitel sonnenschein
wenn ihr dachtet dass die erben die
revolution keine gravierenden negativen
folgen hätte dann solltet ihr jetzt mal
gut aufpassen
[Musik]
aktivisten stürmen das hauptquartier von
rbi wie in san francisco um gegen
hausräumung zu protestieren
ganz genau überall auf der welt tauchen
in den städten plattformen gegen erwin
wie auch tatsächlich werden wir bald
sehen dass erwin wie in vielen städten
verboten oder stark eingeschränkt wird
aber die frage lautet natürlich warum
nun die leute beschweren sich
hauptsächlich aus zwei gründen
der erste ist dass sie einfach keine
touristen in ihrer nachbarschaft haben
wollen sie beschweren sich über den lärm
und die unordnung die einige touristen
nun eben verursachen aber der grösste
grund ist der angeblich treibende
einfluss auf die mietpreise und glaubt
mir sowas kann sich zu einem
ernstzunehmenden und existenziellen
problem auswachsen ich bin sicher viele
von euch wissen bereits wovon ich
spreche
es gibt einen globalen trend die meisten
der größten städte der welt erleben
einen rasanten anstieg der mietpreise
der einfach keine obergrenze zu kennen
scheint in den usa haben städte wie oder
san diego mieterhöhungen von mehr als 15
prozent pro jahr erlebt dasselbe gilt
auch für andere städte wie memphis und
will
[Musik]
in deutschland haben sich die mieten zb
in berlin innerhalb von zehn jahren mehr
als verdoppelt dasselbe vollzieht sich
in madrid oder barcelona und die frage
lautet nun warum eigentlich aus welchem
grund schießen die mietpreise in den
himmel
nun man könnte glauben das lwb etwas
damit zu tun hat
vielleicht ist dies nicht der einzige
faktor aber es könnte ein sehr wichtiger
faktor sein oder
letztendlich können eigentümer mit
touristen viel mehr geld verdienen als
mit normalen mieter nach angaben von lg
in einer analyse websites die tourismus
vermietungen analysiert liegt der
durchschnittspreis für eine nacht in
barcelona bei 187 euro die
durchschnittliche belegungsrate beträgt
81 prozent mit diesen zahlen im
hinterkopf konnte der eigentümer einer
wohnung in barcelona mit dieser bis zu
55.000 euro pro jahr verdienen für
spanische verhältnisse entspricht dies
einem sehr hohen einkommen
[Musik]
und je mehr mietwohnungen in touristen
absteigen umgewandelt werden desto
weniger davon stehen wohnungssuchenden
zur verfügung deren nachfrage bleibt
jedoch bei sinkendem angebot die gleiche
also steigen die preise
und ehrlich gesagt es ist verdammt
schwer diesen thema fundiert auf den
zahn zu fühlen warum weil er so gut wie
keine verlässlichen daten dazu finden
kann mit den recherchen für dieses video
verbrachten wir buchstäblich mehr als
zwei monate schließlich haben wir zwei
arten von quellen verwendet akademische
studien von denen einige direkt von
airbnb stammen und er dna an dieser
stelle möchte ich die zahl von scherrer
institut der wirtschaftsuniversität in
prag für alle die da tolle hilfe danken
und auch ldl dafür dass wir uns alle
notwendigen daten zur verfügung gestellt
haben so und jetzt seid ihr sicher
gespannt zu welchem ergebnis der im
rahmen unserer intensiven studien
gekommen sind die frage lautet also
welchen anteil hat airbnb an den
steigenden mietpreisen wir werden euch
diese frage heute natürlich beantworten
doch zuvor wollte einen blick in die
geschichte werfen
städte gegen bmw es waren einmal in
einem fernen land zwei typen die sich
eine wohnung ist san francisco teilten
aber irgendwann ihre miete nicht mehr
bezahlen konnten und was taten sie dann
da sie ein leeres zimmer hatten
beschlossen sie es an touristen zu
vermieten damals fand in der stadt eine
konferenz statt also verwandelten sie
dieses gästezimmer in ein kleines bed
and breakfast für die teilnehmer der
konferenz und da das einzige bett das
sie anbieten konnten eine aufblasbare
matratze war die website ins netz
stellten um darauf die übernachtung auf
ihrer luftmatratze anzubieten airbnb
ihre geschäftsidee hätte nicht besser
laufen können also beschlossen diese
jungs sie mit dem rest der welt zu
teilen
ursprünglich stand der gedanke daran
touristen für geld in ihrem haus
aufzunehmen und in der tat gibt es auch
heute noch eine menge leute die ihre
hypothek nur dank der vermietung eines
zimmers über ergehen wie bezahlen können
aber das ist nicht das ende dieser
geschichte
sobald diese plattform geboren wurde er
kann man viele menschen dass hier noch
mehr geschäft zu machen ist überleg mal
wenn du mit einem zimmer geld verdienen
kannst wie viel geht dann mit einer
ganzen wohnung so kam es zu einem
unerwarteten trend eigentümer
vermieteten eine ganze wohnung an
zerrissen und macht ihr es nicht den
fehler zu glauben es handle sich nur um
einzelfälle
dieser ansatz ist mittlerweile nicht
mehr in der minderheit bei rw ahlen wie
laut er bmw handelt es sich bei 56
prozent aller angebote in new york um
komplette wohnungen in barcelona machen
diese 47 prozent aus und in los angeles
sogar fast 70 prozent was zunächst nicht
so klar absehbar war entpuppt sich nach
einigem nachdenken als vollkommen
natürliche entwicklung schaut die
verwaltung eine serbien wie apartments
ist ein job für sich
man muss die wohnung renovieren sie
sauber halten den gästen die schlüssel
übergeben wenn du also der eigentümer
einer wohnung bist und nicht viel zeit
hast mach dir keine sorgen es gibt
firmen mit einem rundum sorglos service
die sich gegen provision um euer rbi
angebot können
[Musik]
irgendwie dass der hund wurden alle
städte auf diesem planeten mit tausenden
von rbm vivo nun überzogen um eine
bessere vorstellung davon zu bekommen
die riesig die zahl dieser angebote ist
allein in barcelona sind es mehr als
22.000 wohnungen die über airbnb
vermietet werden gut ist ihr vielleicht
nicht ob dies wirklich viel oder wenig
ist da ja den mars staatlichkeit nun
2011 gab es in barcelona 177.000
vermietete immobilien heute könnte diese
zahl höher liegen aber wenn wir das jahr
2011 als referenz sehen könnte man sagen
dass etwa zwölf prozent aller
mietwohnungen jetzt für airbnb angebote
genutzt werden
und hier beginnt die kontroverse
[Musik]
barcelona findet einen weg zur kontrolle
seine serbien beim akt aber barcelona
ist nicht allein
so verabschiedete berlin im jahr 2016
hingesetzt
das rbb in der ganzen stadt verbot im
grunde musste man um touristen aufnehmen
zu können beim berliner rathaus eine
genehmigung beantragen
die zahl dieser genehmigungen war stark
beschränkt und wurde man ohne sie
erwischt gab es bußgelder von bis zu
100.000 euro im jahr 2018 wurden diese
regeln aufgeweicht beschränkungen
bestehen aber nach wie vor man darf
seine erben wie immobilie haben aber bei
der zweiten gibt es einen 19 tage limit
etwas ähnliches geschieht in los angeles
und japan
das habt ihr richtig gehört japan hat
ein nationales limit für alle dortigen
erwin wie angebotes festgelegt und jetzt
fragt ihr euch vielleicht weiß er wie
wirklich die mieten in den städten die
antwort lautet klar aber das ist nicht
die eigentliche frage denn die
eigentliche frage lautet wie stark wirkt
sich erwin wie auf die mietpreise aus
und hier betreten wir die schöne welt
der nuancen schott die seriöse studie
die wir zu diesem thema haben wurde von
der universität von kalifornien im jahr
2018 durchgeführt sie untersuchten die
auswirkungen von erwin wie in der stadt
boston und nun kommen sie zu folgendem
schluss ist es zu sehen dass ein anstieg
der lbm wie angebot um ein prozent
kausal zu einem anstieg der mietpreise
um 0,01 8 prozent obwohl diese effekte
sehr gering erscheinen mögen muss man
bedenken dass das durchschnittliche
wachstum der zahl der rbi angebote im
jahresvergleich etwa 44 prozent beträgt
diese studie konzentrierte sich auf
posten aber lasst uns diese zahlen mal
auf barcelona hochrechnen um eine ahnung
davon zu bekommen was dort eigentlich
abgeht anhand der daten von ldl wissen
wir dass das wohnungsangebot für
touristen in dieser stadt seit dem jahr
2016 um 22 prozent gestiegen ist damit
hat erwin zu einem anstieg von 0,44
prozent beigetragen
dennoch sind die mieten in barcelona im
gleichen zeitraum um elf prozent
gestiegen
wie ist das wirklich wie ist es möglich
dass er ihn wie einen so geringen
einfluss auf die mietpreise hat okay
lasst uns das mal genauer untersuchen
[Musik]
serbien ist größter mythos während
unserer recherchen für dieses video
sprachen wir mit eine freud' der eine
airbnb wohnung in malaga also einer
stark touristisch geprägten spanischen
stadt besitzt er verdient damit
durchschnittlich 5000 euro im monat das
ist ein ziemlich anständiges einkommen
dafür spannt verhält ist somit könnte
jeder auf den gedanken kommen rbb seien
ziemlich solides wissen ist oder eine
ware gelddruckmaschine warum also sollte
man nicht selbst auf diesen zug
aufspringen wäre doch blöd sich so eine
gelegenheit entgehen zu lassen
ok dann tust doch der bereiche wie unser
freundin spanien aber nicht so schnell
cowboy so einfach ist das nämlich gar
nicht teil der vor du hast eine wohnung
in new york und vermietet diese über
erwin und jeder bis silvester auf dem
time square feiern also wirst du
dezember einen ordentlichen batzen knete
einfahren aber hey dann kommt der januar
und februar und die stadt ist leer
mach dir keine sorgen wir kompensieren
dass mit den sommer erträgen oder der
sommer ist überall eine hochzeit des
tourismus und ja das stimmt aber moment
mal
du bist nicht der einzige der auf diese
idee gekommen ist im sommer stellen alle
ihre wohnungen aus airbnb im februar
2017 beispielsweise hatte in new york
8500 einträge im dezember stiegen diese
auf 19.000 später im februar 2018 gegen
video zu merken was hier abgeht die
größte stärke von airbnb nämlich ist
gleichzeitig auch seine größte schwäche
das ist nämlich keine eintrittsbarrieren
jeder kann hier sein business aufmachen
und das erklärt meldungen wie die folgen
die rbi die gastgeber haben es schwer
gäste für den superbowl zu finden in
diesem fall sprechen wir über den
superbowl 2016 der in santa clara
kalifornien stattfand tausende von
fußballfans waren bereit alles zu
bezahlen um in der stadt übernachten zu
können
die hotels waren voll so beschlossen
tausende von eigentümern ihre wohnungen
an touristen zu vermieten an einem
wochenende könnte man sich ein ganzes
monatsgehalt dazuverdienen
wer würde dies nicht wollen darin lag
geht auf das problem jeder wollte es und
jeder tat ist das angebot übertraf bald
die nachfrage und die preise gingen in
den keller und dieses phänomen erklärt
warum es trotz allem anscheinend seid
2017 zu einer stabilisierung der preise
kam natürlich können wir gewisse
personale aufschläge verzeichnen aber
der juni 2017 unterschied sich nicht so
sehr vom juli 2018 oder 2019 ein hotel
zu betreiben kann ein großartiges
geschäft seien aber touristen wachsen
auch nicht auf bäumen ihre zahl ist
hingegen der meinung vieler menschen den
typischen touristen zielen leben nicht
unendlich wenn ihr also mit dem gedanken
gespielt habt auf die rbi blase
aufzuspringen habe ich schlechte
nachrichten sich die goldenen zeiten
sind bereits vorbei zumindest in den
städten in denen wir zugang zu daten
hatten
was war los angeles new york und
barcelona aber bedeutet das dass ihr mit
rbi gar kein geld mehr verdienen könnt
natürlich nicht man sollte sich aber
schon ein wenig mit den touristen
geschäft auskennen und falls ihr nicht
mehr ruhig schlafen konnte aus angst die
rbi flut würde die wohnungsnot in
katastrophal höhen treiben wir können
euch da boeing es sieht es nicht danach
aus als ob diesem absehbarer zeit
geschehen würde aber wartet noch einen
moment denn da ist noch etwas anderes
wenn ihr euch diese karten an seht euch
vielleicht etwas aus es gibt airbnb
einträge in allen stadtteilen zb könnt
ihr auf dieser karte von new york sehen
die ganz manhattan mit angeboten bedeckt
ist aber queens und bronx sind fast leer
und das ist noch nicht alles siehst du
die zwei arten von blasen auf der karte
da sind die wetten und die blaue die
violetten sind ganze listen und die
blauen sind einzelzimmer
wenn ihr aufmerksam seid seht ihr ein
klares muster je weiter wir uns vom
zentrum entfernen desto weniger violett
und desto mehr blau gibt es also ja in
den touristenzentren die auch die
teuersten angebote haben damit die
eigentümer lieber an touristen aber je
weiter man sich von diesen gebieten
entfernt desto öfter nutzen die menschen
lbm wie einfach nur um mit einem
überschüssigen leeren zimmer ein kleines
zusatzeinkommen zu verdienen abgesehen
davon wo entfaltet seine wirkung am
stärksten natürlich nicht in den
wohngebieten der mittleren und unteren
preiskategorie airbnb hat den größten
einfluss auf die mietpreise in den
teuersten skrtel und das erklärte
meldungen wie diese die nachbarn von
sant antoni in barcelona klagen seit
jahren über den tourismus um mit diesen
punkt zu veranschaulichen hat eine
zivile plattform eine map of shame
erstellt die einige der touristen
wohnungen in der nachbarschaft an den
pranger stellt sant antoni liegt in der
stadtmitte von barcelona wenn erwin wie
also im durchschnitt einen einfluss von
0,4 prozent auf den mietpreis hat liegt
dieser wert hier vermutlich höher
abschließend kann man also sagen das ist
folglich viele gründe gibt daran zu
zweifeln airbnb habe einen besonders
großen einfluss auf das mietpreisniveau
natürlich es gibt noch viele andere
nebenwirkungen von airbnb über die wir
diskutieren können aber mieterhöhung
gehören nicht dazu aber eine frage haben
wir immer noch nicht beantwortet wenn
nicht er wer wie was treibt der an die
mieten in den größten städten der welt
in die höhe nun diese frage werden wir
in einem weiteren video beantworten
und wenn ihr dieses oder andere beiträge
nicht verpassen wollte abonniert bitte
wissen politik und drückt bitte auf das
glöckchen damit ihr rechtzeitig eine
benachrichtigung bekommt in der
zwischenzeit lasse ich euch ein paar
fragen zum nachdenken gibt es eine
möglichkeit den anstieg der mietpreise
irgendwie aufzuhalten oder geht dies gar
nicht und wir können nichts anderes tun
als auf den nächsten natürlichen crash
zu warten
bitte teilt eure meinung mit uns und
anderen im kommentarbereich unter diesem
video und wenn wir dann das video zu
diesem thema veröffentlichen
könnt ihr eure antwort mit der unseren
vergleichen falls euch dieses video
gefallen hat geht uns einen daumen hoch
was gut ist zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]